I'm Jimmy phela I'm Madison allworth I'm
Bill hemmer and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday April 5th 2023 I'm Jared
Halpert for the first time in American
history a former president is arrested
and arraigned on felony charges but it
isn't slowing down Donald Trump's
front-running Republican campaign the
overall sense of grievance the overall
tone the overall belief that the elites
and the establishment are out to get the
average guy I mean that is the sweet
spot for Trump's rhetoric I'm Alex Hogan
the nation's top defense officials
testified before Congress warning that
the U.S military must outpace China's in
order to maintain peace however some
believe that our military's development
is growing weaker we are well behind the
Chinese and that ought to just sober us
all to the threat that we face and I'm
Nicole Parker I've got the final word on
the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
not guilty Donald Trump the former
president and candidate to service 47th
president uttered those words entering a
plea in a New York City courtroom on 34
felony counts the former president
surrendered to authorities he was booked
and walked showing no obvious emotion
into a courtroom to face a judge the
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
says Trump falsified business records to
conceal hush money payments made to
women alleging Affairs ahead of the 2016
election Donald Trump was arraigned on a
New York Supreme Court indictment
returned by a Manhattan grand jury
on 34 felony counts falsifying business
records in the first degree Bragg says
he took office additional evidence was
made available that his predecessor did
not have leading to his decision to seek
a grand jury's indictment I bring cases
women already having now conducted a
rigorous thorough investigation the case
was ready to be brought and it was
brought photographs from inside the
courtroom showed former president Trump
seated at the defense table between his
team of lawyers he did not make any
remarks to reporters on his way in or
out of court instead immediately flying
back and holding a campaign-style
response surrounded by hundreds of
supporters at Mar-A-Lago the only crime
that I have committed is to fearlessly
defend our nation from those who seek to
destroy it Trump also addressed separate
investigations in Georgia and if the U.S
justice department looking in the
potential criminality surrounding
allegations that could also lead the
Char charges and more Court proceedings
the legal Peril has so far had no
noticeable impact on the former
president's third run for office his
campaign reports raising millions of
dollars over the past few days and
polling shows Trump Remains the Far and
Away front runner for the Republican
nomination it's never good legally when
a former president presidential
candidate is going to court and pleading
not guilty to a felony Josh crossauer is
a Fox News Radio political analyst that
said when we look at Republican primary
politics these days Donald Trump is
still beloved by the Republican base
his voters and Republican voters writ
large view him as being wronged by brag
by by the other District Attorneys and
they agree that he's being aggrieved and
look that this Dynamic is not going to
change anytime soon Trump is now sucking
the political oxygen out of the room
right before a lot of Republicans like
Rhonda Santos were getting ready to
announce their their presidential
campaigns and I I think the challenging
Dynamic writ large for Trump's
Republican Challengers now is that it's
going to be hard for them to get a whole
lot of attention as long as this cloud
and perhaps future legal clouds are
hanging over the former president
because that's really an important part
of this story too right is we saw this
history happen yesterday in lower
Manhattan the first time ever that a
former president has faced a judge been
arrested all of that but I think the
point you're making is it may not be the
last time you have the investigation in
Georgia you have the special counsel
investigations at the justice department
those two could end in some sort of
legal Peril for Donald Trump and if they
do
how is that campaign sustainable
right a few months ago if you asked me
whether Trump you know faced bigger
political danger or legal danger you
know I thought that this was going to be
litigated through the political system
through the primary uh campaign you know
and I I actually think now that Trump's
fate may end up being determined through
these cases whether it's uh D.A Bragg's
case which I think looks like the
flimsiest okay the good news for Donald
Trump Jared is that uh a lot of legal
voices on the left a lot of anti-trump
Republicans like Mitt Romney or Jeb Bush
have been very critical of D.A Bragg and
and the case that he brought it's not as
substantive if you believe the legal
analysis as a lot of anti-trump uh folks
had hoped for but as you know Jared
there are two other big cases or you
know you have the The Fulton County case
with fonnie Willis in Georgia uh focused
on whether Trump undermined the the
Georgia election by threatening the
Georgia Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger and you have the the
special counsel Jack Smith's uh
investigation over January 6th and also
the former president's alleged
mishandling of sensitive government
records so there are a bunch of legal
balls that the Trump folks are going to
be juggling potentially and you're right
that we don't know where that's going to
go politically though boy just look at
every every poll that's come out in the
last few weeks both right around the
time of the indictment and the few polls
we've seen post indictment Trump has a
surged to a 30 35 point lead in the in
the primary he's doing his butt as well
as he he's done in the polls ever since
leaving office and it's hard to see in
the short or medium term that that
Dynamic changing anytime soon
one of the issues as well as we sort of
look at how the legal aspect of this and
the political aspect of this intertwine
is this uh looming question of a gag
order and the judge overseeing uh this
case is not imposed one but is sort of
uh warned both sides that you know the
rhetoric needs to stay respectful in
that he could change his calculation as
it relates to a uh a gag order you know
in the remarks that Trump made it at
Mar-A-Lago he in passing sort of made a
I think he called the judge a trump
hater or his family Trump haters
um it's been obviously very critical of
prosecutors is that going to be a a
needle that Trump is going to have to
threat as he goes back out here on the
campaign Trail over the next uh several
months because again the next court
session is not expected before December
4th
that's right I mean look Trump listening
to that speech is playing with legal
fire he he went after the prosecutor
brag he went after the judge Smith
judge's daughter uh boy I mean look you
know I I certainly think that Trump's
lawyers are going to be talking to him
and urging him to zip it up going
forward uh that may have opened Trump up
to some additional legal Jeopardy I
don't know how the judge will respond
but boy that was a frontal attack
against the judge who's going to be
hearing the evidence and deciding uh or
at least overseeing this case uh in in
New York and I boy I can't imagine
Trump's legal team listened to the
comments at Mar-A-Lago and thought he
was doing himself any good
let's talk about the field the emerging
Republican field by and large even those
who are already in the race or those who
are probably very close to jumping in
the race have been
very supportive of trump as it relates
to this indictment right they have
questioned uh the validity of it they
have accused the the D.A of this
political prosecution and not a legal
prosecution what is the strategy here if
you are challenging Donald Trump for the
Republican nomination how do you sort of
appeal to that base which is sizable
while also trying to chart your own
course and if you have not yet gotten
into the race are you reconsidering it
after what we've seen over the last few
weeks
well number one the fact that almost
every leading rival to Trump for the
Republican nomination defended the the
former president tells you all you need
to know about where the Republican party
is Circa April 2023. he usually when
when a candidate is indicted you go out
you attack them you would think that
would be like the first line of attack
right that is like you know my opponent
has been indicted case closed right I
mean yeah that's that's politics 101.
politics 101 candidate indicted the fact
that everyone other than Chris Christie
and newly minted candidate ASA
Hutchinson that that Rhonda santis Nikki
Haley you know Glenn young everyone in
the mix for the presidential campaign
defended uh the the front-runner uh it
tells you all you need to know about
where the Republican party is and
frankly if they can they're not going to
go after Trump for you know being
indicted uh it's gonna be hard to so I
mean
what do they do to run against Trump
then well ultimately that's what they're
doing right they're trying to convince
Republican voters that you know even if
they are all in on everything that Trump
did as president it's time to turn the
page it's time to move on how do you
make that argument while also saying he
is you know being made an example of and
this is unfair and this is unjust and
they're going after you and the movement
in all of that right
the best way I think to understand the
Republican strategies for looking at
DeSantis or Haley or the leading
Challengers is that they're they're kind
of praying or hoping or keeping their
fingers crossed that the legal Jeopardy
the legal challenges that Trump faces
become so significant that maybe he
can't feasibly run for president and
deal with his legal case and if that is
the case then perhaps being seen as a
pro-trump republican uh will carry some
weight if Trump isn't actually running
in the end I I think that's wishful
thinking I think given how uh legal
experts have analyzed the New York case
I think uh that's going to push him out
of the presidential campaign is is
fanciful there's been a lot of Wishful
Thinking in Republican politics for the
last uh eight years or so and I think
this is one more example of no one being
willing to frontally attack Trump
they're worried that the voters in the
Republican Party overwhelmingly are
supportive of Trump no matter what and
they're afraid to be the one person
going after him and finding their own
support dissipating if they do so we'll
finish with this the speech that the
former president delivered at Mar-A-Lago
here uh following his arraignment in New
York City covered a lot of ground it was
about 20 minutes or so 21 22 minutes is
that the model now for for the events
for the rallies he's going to have
moving forward in other words did we
sort of get a preview now of what a I
guess we could call it a stump speech
might look like uh while he is moving
forward and fighting these criminal
charges
I don't think so I I think his campaign
if you talk to his advisors tonight that
they don't want that to be the stump
speech they they'll rather have a
two-hour greatest hits of 2020 than than
what you saw look that was a parade of
grievances he got into quite a Litany of
arguments against some of these cases
against him but uh that that's not the
greatest hits that was legal minutia and
and just kind of just an angry Trump
letting off some steam in Mar-A-Lago it
reminded me a little bit more of a low
energy performance uh in Mar-A-Lago when
he announced his campaign uh last
November so I I don't think if that's
what you're going to be seeing from
Trump uh after after his legal
predicament that then maybe it is good
news for the other Republicans looking
to make some inroads but look I people
have written Trump off Trump has been
down but he's never been out and uh I I
was surprised Jared just watching him on
the campaign Trail seen him in person I
expected more of the the kind of
original uh kind of despondent figure
and he turned things around and he
actually uh had a had a pretty sharp
message at CPAC and at some of the other
events he's done over the last couple
months so look I I don't think his
advisors want him to repeat that speech
that they want him to avoid the legal
talk on the campaign Trail uh the more
he talks about minutia like that the
more he's gonna put his audiences to
sleep but he does the overall sense of
grievance the overall tone the overall
belief that the elites and the
establishment are out to get the average
guy I mean that is the sweet spot for
Trump's rhetoric and I think you'll be
hearing those broad themes uh and you'll
continue to hear those broad themes in
the in the campaign trail from Trump in
the days and months to come all right
well we are uh months away from the
first uh ballads being cast caucus goers
and primary voters casting ballots and
we'll have a lot more discussions uh
between uh now and then uh Josh
crossauer always a pleasure enjoyed the
conversation uh we'll talk soon thanks
Jared
[Music]
this is Nicole Parker with your Fox News
commentary coming up
how long will U.S support the war in
Ukraine and what does China's rapid
expansion of its military mean for the
U.S those are just a couple of the
questions that Army General Mark milley
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and defense secretary Floyd Austin took
from members of Congress General Mark
milley explains we don't want a great
fire war with China we want to prevent
that the way to prevent it is a strong
powerful military a demonstrated will to
use it if necessary and that they
clearly and unambiguously understand it
China has been a main focus these
hearings as concerns from top defense
officials grow that the Chinese military
May outpace our own as the U.S is
grappling with a military recruitment
crisis defense secretary Lloyd Austin
tried to assure lawmakers that the
military was tackling this issue this is
not the first time that the military has
been faced with challenges in recruiting
it'll take a while to uh to come out of
that bathtub and and get to where we
need to be but I am confident that we'll
get there meanwhile lawmakers on Capitol
Hill have been emphasizing their
concerns as intelligence shows that
China has been heavily investing in its
own Armed Forces well listen it's grown
significantly joining me is Congressman
Rob Whitman of Virginia I put a slide up
the other day in our hearing there on
the house armed services committee and
it's staggering the growth that we've
seen in the Chinese military from
essentially
1999 to present and then the track that
they're on for future military growth
they outpace Us in just about every
element of our strategic forces whether
it's ships whether it's weapons whether
it's land systems you know those things
that you need for an army land Vehicles
tanks artillery all of those elements
they have outpaced us in space although
we are catching up there they have uh
also had another uh area that's that's
really concerning to me and that is
hypersonics so they have uh really
accelerated uh what they're doing in
hypersonics we're running the catch up
the single place where we have an
advantage over them is in in the
undersea world are submarine forces
about the only place where we have any
superiority and if you take the total
formula and add it up we are well behind
the Chinese and that ought to just sober
us all to the threat that we face it's
what keeps me up at night the challenge
that we face now and it only gets larger
in the future if we really don't get our
resolve on track to counter what the
Chinese are doing so what is it
specifically that you're proposing well
on a number of different levels for
first of all is is you know we cannot
capitulate to the Chinese we have to
work in all the different areas this
isn't just a strategic battle it's also
a battle in in the fiscal areas we have
to we have to be very aggressive to make
sure that uh people know when they are
investing in funds that actually go to
the Chinese Communist Party another
thing too is U.S companies cannot
capitulate to China and turn over their
intellectual property which is how China
operates we also have to build a
military uh that has the ability to
counter China and we have to build it in
smart ways we have to build things that
can immediately pose a threat to China
going off of that at the military budget
hearing you argue that the budget
doesn't meet the realities of the
threats from our adversaries but
secretary Austin's counter argument to
that is that really what we're looking
at is the quality of the Coalition not
specifically the quantity the numbers
noting that allies and partners would be
a part of that Coalition and ensuring
that there would be extra support so
what is your response to his counter
argument my response to his counter
argument is that's not correct period
it's it's not correct from this
standpoint quantity has a quality all of
its own if you look at all the aspects
for the Chinese outpace us not only in
quantity but now in quality they are
putting together platforms that are
incredibly incredibly uh effective and
can hold us at risk at long distance I
mean to the point where we can't even
get inside that that threat ring to
deliver our weapons and you know it's
great to have friends but the question
is will our friends be there if an
outbreak occurs we don't have a formal
agreements that say if there is a
conflict with China that these allies
will be there with us it's totally up to
them as to whether or not they're going
to be there so the question is is China
tries to take Taiwan will those friends
be there it's great to have these
relationships but will those friends go
to battle with us
yeah well speaking of impacts of other
countries around the world other
territories and you've talked about this
uh at a great deal saying that we need
to be watching what China is doing
around the world so in terms of of Aid
and investments in Africa and Central
America what are some of the points that
you're arguing in that
well I'm arguing that where China is
investing is in areas that will provide
them resources that they need to grow
economically but also to grow militarily
and strategically if you look at uh Rare
Earth elements critical critical
minerals they are around the world
getting into these countries South
America and Africa uh exercising their
negotiating skills with those countries
getting agreements that allow them to uh
to access to process those those those
Rare Earth elements those critical
minerals you know they they they have
about 70 percent of the extraction
capability uh throughout the world
seventy percent of what's available in
the world they have the extraction
capability there they have about 90
percent of the refining capability so
let's put this in reality of what China
is doing around the world and this and
they're not there to be friends with
those countries they are there as a
trans actional Nation they are there to
say hey here we'll give you a little bit
but in return they have these long-term
agreements that let them extract and
process these critical minerals around
the world would that not be somewhat of
a similar argument that maybe China
would have in response to the U.S and
other allies making investments in
general around the world in other
developing countries well we are not
making those same sorts of Investments
yeah I really wish wish we were they are
making strategic Investments you know
when usaid goes to these different
countries and helps you know we're
looking to do basic things like feed
people like provide Health Care to
people those are the places where where
we are investing uh China's versus 100
transactional they'll come in and build
a road or build a building and go look
look how nice we are to you but then
they are there to exploit those natural
resources so even people in the country
aren't benefiting from this that's how
transactional China
now Switching gears a little bit back to
another main topic that we heard at this
military budget hearing was Ukraine so
one of the repeated topics both in terms
of of weapons provided and the long-term
commitment to supporting the war so what
were some of the the feedback the
comments that marked you the most of
what was most that maybe possibly the
largest takeaways from that topic well
it's not I think there's several things
one is is that we need to do everything
possible to make sure that the weapons
that we're sending there are in the
hands of Ukrainian military members and
that they are being utilized on the
front and I understand we have inspector
generals there on the ground that's
great I understand that we are going to
extraordinary links to make sure we're
tracking all of that that's great but I
still think that there's some elements
that are missing I haven't seen or heard
from anybody that there's actually an
intelligence operation trying to gather
intelligence on who might be trying to
intercept these weapons I think it's I
think it's fine to help Ukraine I do
think in the long term that helps the
United States especially if this could
spill over into NATO countries that
would invoke Article Five and then we
would be involved with boots on the
ground but I think it's incredibly
important to have a strategy because you
can't just keep writing the check on
infinite and without any understanding
about what's what's the what's the
strategy and part of that conversation
during the hearing was that the goal
according to President Biden has
remained that Ukraine must remain a free
state with all of its territories intact
in one of the conversations in that was
that Ukrainian president bolanimir
zielinski has said that territory
includes Crimea which has of course been
contested since 2014 so did that alarm
you well that you know that's that's
another condition that makes it
incredibly difficult going forward uh to
seek any sort of agreement with Russia I
don't know that that's where any sort of
negotiation to end the conflict would
would end up and and obviously Russia
wants all the Eastern territory in
Ukraine as well as Crimea essentially a
land bridge to Crimea and Ukraine is
going to want all that territory to
remain Sovereign in addition to the area
in Crimea that it was taken against
their will so I understand that's where
both sides are going to start off the
question is is that where they will end
other topics discussed of course at this
hearing or the development of
Technologies whether that's Hypersonic
technology artificial intelligence
investing in training the family members
involved health care for service members
continually protecting our country in
all of this was there anything that
struck you that you were you were
especially pleased with during this
hearing well yes I I think that they're
uh that there are efforts to make sure
that in the area
of taking care of our military families
that folks are very aware how incredibly
important that is in fact I was just
speaking today with General mcconville
who's the chief of the army and they
understand that there are issues with
recruiting and for that matter of
attention really center around what are
they doing to take care of soldiers and
their families and and I think that's
key you know it's it's one thing to
realize that but it's another thing to
make sure that comes to fruition also
you know the effort to modernize our
military has to take place at a at a
significant rate and what I call the
rate of relevance we have to make sure
that we have a force that's relevant
tomorrow and the day after you know the
days where we had years and years and
years to develop new platforms because
there was nobody that was competing with
us those days are gone we have to have a
level of urgency in how we develop new
weapon systems and we have to be
thoughtful too because there's not an
unlimited amount of resources in the
United States I want to make sure that
each and every day Xi Jinping wakes up
and goes no not today because he looks
at the scenario and says no I just don't
think things are going to end well if we
try to take Taiwan if we try to take on
the United States today but I'm still
very very mindful that he will I believe
try to test Us in every in every way
possible Congressman Rob Whitman thanks
so much for joining me thank you for
your Insight and your time Alex thank
you
[Music]
I'm Gianna jalosi what's that smell
smelling other people's body odor is
usually undesirable but a study from
Sweden suggests Bo could also be an
alternative therapy for social anxiety
the lead researcher said when people are
in a certain state of mind and then
sweat their perspiration includes
certain molecules or chemo signals that
convey their emotional state and elicit
corresponding responses to those that
smell it the researchers collected sweat
from volunteers who watch clips of
movies to induce emotions next 48 women
who were experiencing social anxiety
were exposed to different odors some of
which included those sweat samples along
with mindfulness therapy they found that
sweat therapy when combined with
mindfulness produce better results in
treating social anxiety than mindfulness
alone but researchers were also
surprised to find sweat produced while
someone was happy had the same effect as
someone who had been scared by that
movie clip the researchers planned to do
an additional study to confirm these
findings and they're working to
determine which molecules in human sweat
reduce anxiety levels for the Fox News
rundown I'm Gian jalosi
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
I'm Dana Perino join me for season three
of my limited time podcast everything
will be okay based on my best-selling
book of the same name make sure you
subscribe to this series wherever you
download podcasts and leave a rating and
review subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary Nicole Parker what's
on your mind who wants to feel that they
were hired for a job in order to fill a
quota
certainly not me on February 24th 2019 a
fellow FBI agent told me there was a
photograph of me published On The Wall
Street journal's website I was puzzled
as agents we avoid the media I check
their website sure enough there was an
article titled FBI's most wanted more
applicants for special agents it
included an open source photograph of me
wearing my FBI Ray jacket conducting an
investigation with the caption the FBI
has shifted recruitment efforts to reach
more minority and female candidates
I was demoralized as it implied that I
was some token female agent hire that
was exactly what I tried to distance
myself from being labeled as my entire
FBI career I shared this with humility I
was told by an FBI interviewer that I
earned a perfect score on the phase 2
oral exam he explained it was rare as he
could count on one hand the number of
candidates who had received a perfect
score in his 20 plus years of testing
applicants I was not a courtesy check
the box to fulfill the female special
agent quota hire and no one should be
tenacity perseverance and integrity
enabled me to financially support myself
since I got my first job at the age of
15.
there has been a lowering of the
eligibility requirements to become an
FBI special agent and many believe that
hurts the agency's overall performance
this concerned many of my former
colleagues who surmised that the
standards were lower to accommodate a
more diverse Workforce as a woman I do
not believe it is appropriate to reduce
any hiring requirement or process to
accommodate my gender one should be
hired based on their Merit period
these are a few examples that illustrate
the lowering of agent requirements the
FBI lowered the physical fitness test
also known as the PFT score necessary to
enter Quantico significantly
the FBI has made a drug use requirement
more lenient in 2010 when I started the
FBI Academy at Quantico the new agent
training was 20 weeks it has been
reduced to 16 weeks FBI special agents
should be hired and promoted based on
their credentials agents must be fully
confident the individuals going through
a door with them on a dangerous
operation are qualified
you must be willing to put your life on
the line to protect one another and
innocent civilians unfortunately some
skilled individuals who may have wanted
to apply for the FBI in the past may not
have an interest now because of its
tarnish reputation furthermore there is
a general disrespect for law enforcement
because of the defund the police
anti-cop atmosphere that has swept the
nation
this has led to a mass Exodus of
experienced Law Enforcement Officers
although candidates are allegedly
applying to the FBI in droves what
matters is candidate quality not
quantity
no one should be hired in order to
fulfill a quota
as a female I find that insulting no one
wants to feel like a Pity hire but more
importantly there is much at stake
competent and qualified FBI agents hired
based on strict criteria equate to
Safety and Security for Americans in
times of Crisis most do not care what
the identity of the person is protecting
them they care that they and their loved
ones are being protected by the bravest
most capable and honorable agents the
FBI should keep their standards high for
new recruits Americans deserve this this
is Nicole Parker former FBI special
agent
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad-free on
Fox News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
hey it's Will Kane co-host of Fox and
Friends Weekend join me as I share my
thoughts on a wide range of topics from
Sports and pop culture to politics and
business so will Kane podcast subscribe
and listen now at foxnewspodcasts.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes